extintores para nublar la vista de las
fuerzas de seguridad en rangún desde
primera hora de la mañana la policía se
apresura a dispersar a los manifestantes
utilizando gases lacrimógenos balas de
goma y también munición real
los servicios de emergencia de la ciudad
siguen sumando muertos en una nueva
jornada de represión igual que la ciudad
de mandalay y en el norte la segunda
ciudad más grande del país un balance
que cada vez pesa más al menos 30
personas han sido ya asesinadas desde el
inicio del movimiento muertes que
magnifican la ira la muerte de un
manifestante asesinado la semana pasada
no disuadió a sus amigos de protestar el
martes durante su funeral
queremos democracia justicia para
nuestros héroes que dieron la vida por
esta revolución seguiremos luchando
hasta que la justicia esté de nuestro
lado desde el golpe de estado-militar
del 1 de febrero la junta militar ha
endurecido las penas por alterar el
orden público los periodistas están
pagando el precio este miércoles seis
periodistas que cubrían las protestas
fueron acusados de incitar a la
desobediencia civil en el marco
diplomático poco progreso los países de
la asean no han pedido con una sola voz
el retorno a la democracia y se
conforman con pedir al ejército
contención y diálogo
manjavacas carne esto nos preocupa
porque la democracia birmana está
amenazada pero también porque la paz y
la seguridad en la región pueden verse
afectadas ya que emanan aguas
naciones unidas- celebrará el viernes
una reunión del consejo de seguridad
sobre la situación en mianmar la
institución tendrá que decidir qué
representa mianmar en su seno
representante que estaba en el cargo
hasta ahora fue destituido por la junta
tras condenar el golpe de estado pero
informó que no va a dimitir y que la
junta no tiene derecho a retirarlo de su
cargo